Ransomware is everywhere.
It's happening to the biggest companies.
The cyber weapon NotPetya
started in Ukraine
in June of 2017.
It quickly spread,
paralyzing major companies
and causing more than
$10 billion in damage.
Government computers in 22 Texas towns
are being held hostage by ransomware.
But it's also happening
at super low levels,
where you have people
ransoming individuals for
small amounts of money.
And the thing that was most interesting
and the thing that sort
of set us down this path
is this thing called
ransomware as a service.
And as soon as you hear that phrase,
I mean, I want to read about that.
The idea that people could
buy ransomware the same way
they buy Salesforce
software or anything else.
And so then we decided to send
Drake out into the dark web
to procure some ransomware service.
With a story like this,
all the reasons not to do it
are actually the reasons to do it.
My name's Drake Bennett.
I went on the dark web,
I bought some malware
and I used it to attack and
extort my editor Max Chafkin.
The original idea
was just to do something about ransomware.
The city of Baltimore was having this huge
sort of battle with some hackers.
Thousands of Baltimore city computers
frozen by hackers demanding ransom.
Baltimore's government computer systems
recently faced a ransomware attack.
Are you seeing these attacks
become more sophisticated?
The more I learned about this world,
the more frustrated I got.
It seems hard to know
what you can trust here.
There's a lot of anonymity.
The more I thought about it,
the more it seemed like
it might make sense to try it myself.
He wanted to do something participatory.
It's really a cool way
to explain a really
difficult technical topic.
And then that also has the added benefit
of testing out a hypothesis
I'd begun to have,
which is that this
stuff has gotten so easy
for a variety of reasons
that almost anyone could
launch one of these attacks.
And as it happens,
I'd be a particularly
good guinea pig for this
because I'm particularly
technologically illiterate.
You got to have a hacker,
and that hacker despite his,
I'd say modest computing skills,
is Drake and the victim was me.
And our idea was that
Drake could, you know,
he's sending me attachments all the time,
so the way we decided he was
gonna do it is he was gonna
pretend to send me a draft,
but that draft was gonna be ransomware.
- What were some of the legal concerns and
how did you get around that?
Okay.
Legal concerns.
What we figured out in
consultation with a very amused
and maybe slightly confused
Bloomberg lawyer, was that--
All of the laws that are on the books
require not only the
possession of malware,
but the intent to
actually launch an attack
against an unwitting victim.
Max, my victim was
complicit in the scheme,
so we figured that kept us
on the right side of the law.
And I do think there's a really strong
public interest argument
for doing this kind of thing
because if somebody as unsophisticated
as a magazine journalist
can get really dangerous ransomware
without spending very much money,
that's something that I think
the public needs to know about.
So once we kind of talked
to a Bloomberg lawyer,
we then got two burner laptops,
we got two cheap Dell laptops.
Max and I both work for a company
that takes data security very
seriously for obvious reasons,
so we made sure
that we kept all this
off Bloomberg's network.
Then we decided to send him
onto the dark web to procure
some ransomware service.
So there are these dark web forums
that work sort of like they're chat rooms,
but they're also these
kind of malware bazaars
where you can go and people are hawking
different forms of malware
and also different ways
of getting that malware
onto computer systems.
The market has now kind of advanced
to the point where there
are these services,
they're called ransomware as a service,
and it's a play on this idea
of software as a service
or SaaS, which is something you hear
in Silicon Valley all the time.
And so I found a couple,
some of them turned out to be bogus,
some of them seemed to be defunct.
People just didn't get back to me.
But there was one where
the guy got back to me
when I got in touch with him
and answered the few questions I had.
And it was cheap, it was just 150 bucks,
so I figured it was worth a try.
So the first thing I did is
I reached out to the vendor
and I used ProtonMail, which
is an encrypted email service.
And at that point I had gone ahead
and set up a Bitcoin wallet,
so I paid the $150 that
was the subscription fee
for the service and that gave
me a login for this website.
And it was a pretty
simple looking interface.
There was a series of tabs
at the top of the screen.
One of the tabs took me to
the quote unquote dashboard,
which is where I'd be able to
manage the various attacks.
There was another tab
that took me to what
was called the builder,
which is a page that allowed
me to input a few pieces
of information about the
kind of malware I wanted.
Stuff like what kind of operating system
would be on the target computer
or what kind of encryption
I wanted or what's the email address
that my victims should use to contact me
once they realize they've been attacked.
So I input those few pieces of information
and it spits out a piece of software
that I could then
download onto my computer.
So it became obvious pretty quickly
that I didn't have
particularly top shelf product.
And that's not surprising.
A lot of the conversation
on these dark web forums
is about whether this or that product
is reliable or how well it works.
The person that we bought
the ransomware from
turned out to be not
the most sophisticated.
Almost as unsophisticated as we were.
And it kind of started to become unclear
whether he was trying to
con us out of more money,
and I kept saying to him,
"We got to be really careful
that there's not an
additional layer to this scam,
that he's not gonna ask us
to wire him some more money
to make the software work better,"
which is what he was trying to do.
So there's just like so much con artistry.
And there does seem to be a wide range
in quality reflected partly
in the wide range of price.
There are other ones that
are much more high end
where it's not even an annual fee model
it's more like you have a gang of hackers
with different specialties
and they just divide up
the pot between them.
So I wrote my email to
Max, which basically said,
'Hey Max, here's the
draft of my latest story.
Sorry it's taken so long.
The draft is attached'.
Even though I had a really bad laptop,
it immediately sniffed
out the potential
that this attachment that
Drake was sending me,
which looked super suspicious
to me, was going to do harm,
and there were a bunch of
warning boxes that opened up
saying, "Are you really sure
you want to load up this file?
Are you super sure?"
And of course I said yes,
yes, and infected myself.
And then Max looked away for a second
and looked back at his computer
and there was this
ghoulish image of a hand
reaching out from a cloud of
smoke and a message that said,
"All of your files have
now been encrypted."
And, so I was sitting there waiting
for this thing to happen.
We had a photographer there.
All of the documents,
you know I had to load the
laptop with a bunch of documents
that I wasn't afraid to lose.
So I didn't have anything
important on there.
And there's still something really scary
about seeing that message on your computer
that says that they own you now,
that the attacker has your files
and is gonna do with you what he wants.
And it really makes you realize
how easy it is to become a victim.
The communities of people
who are in this world
range from the most sophisticated hackers,
so like, state-supported,
connected to the military
or intelligence operation
of some of the most powerful
countries in the world,
all the way down to
literally a bored teenager.
After all this was over I did reach out
to my ransomware providers
and announce myself
as a journalist and you know,
they consented to be interviewed
and basically what they told me,
they didn't say much about themselves
but they did say that they were a group
of 18 to 26-year-olds with
different specializations
working as a team to create this stuff.
A lot of these chatrooms
where these products
are bought and sold are
Russian language chatrooms.
Some of them have actually
been geofenced or coded
in such a way that they'll work anywhere
except in places like Russia, Ukraine.
But I don't know where particularly
my providers were located.
I also think it was
surprising in a good way
that we really had to
work to make this work
in terms of me ignoring warnings
that my computer was giving.
In terms of Drake having
to work with an expert
to get the ransomware to work perfectly,
but it's just kind of
like a scary reminder
of how all of this kind of,
there are all these sort
of bad actors and creeps
and con artists kind of
lingering just below the surface
of the internet and just
creepy how close they are
and how you're not that far
away from downloading something
that can kind of mess
up your digital life.